A traditional painting is
typically oil on canvas,
protected with a layer
of natural resin varnish.
Over time, a linen
canvas can become
brittle, distort and
sometimes tear.
The conservators begin
with spot tests to
observe how different
colors in the painting
react to cleaning.
They dip a cotton swab
in mild detergent and rub
gently testing for
discolored varnish and
any previous
restoration. Next, they
spray the back of the
canvas with water and lie
the painting on a vacuum
hot table.
The heat turns the
moisture to steam, which
relaxes the paint and
linen as the vacuum pulls
the bumps and puckers
flat.
If the canvas isn't
structurally sound, they
apply adhesive a
synthetic backing, then a
new linen canvas with
thermometers monitoring
the temperature. The
heat activates the
adhesive and the vacuum
draws everything taut
against the hot table.